how old are you i'm 36. how old are you
35. i don't believe you now you don't
because i look younger you look older
[Music]
ah
today you woke up and chose violence
i want problems
i don't want peace
i have seen enough white women in my
life i know when they have gone past you
like a ripe avocado it has gone brown at
the wrong time
okay it is like getting an apple looks
fine on the outside then you touch it
you go
no my friend
we have good fruit in africa for that
reason do i come to a better life to eat
fruit from back home
for what reason do i come to a better
life to eat fruit from the future i am
in the present i do not want the past i
want the right now
my friend you are past due that means
that you have gone too far to the future
that you are in my past
think about it it is quite wise
[Music]
we're going to continue huh i'm not
going to stay on this point too long eh
white women if you are watching i'm
sorry you have become an unnecessary
casualty of war
it's okay if your feelings are hurt
imagine black people in colonization
you are going to make it the same way we
have made it we are here today you are
past due i think they're both going to
try to buzz each other yeah yeah yeah
and i think her pettiness is so high
she's going to buzz him out first
my suspicion yeah let's see i look older
than 35
yes that's so mean i don't mean to be
rude wow
you [ __ ] out there need to know
what the difference is between mean
and an impression are not an opinion an
opinion is not necessarily mean it's not
because it hurts your feelings that it's
mean
you don't look 26 my girl if someone
gives you over 36 i want to be like um
i'm not gonna give you 25. no no i'm not
even gonna front you that's mad that's
matter that's crazy that's crazy i've
been a lot of days that's crazy it
depends
no no no no that's crazy okay
with all the botox and everything and
stuff
hey let me know in the comments comments
on the side put a one if you thought
that was that was too much put a two if
you thought just right you really do
have beautiful teeth though you have a
really nice thank you and you have a
really sincere voice
voice
what'd i tell you bro yeah see she her
hands were ready she's saying get this
oh my goodness he's been insulting her
yeah i get i get i get the flip because
it's like saying yeah girl you're
punctual
my suspicion this guy was hired to make
content
you think i think 100 they said come on
here
shout out to andrew shaw's be flickering
that that i can see that yes the cut is
so [ __ ] messy
they would definitely hire people to
come on and be disturbed as possible yes
you never do that to a woman hey
good how are you thank you mackenzie
josh nice to meet you too
how old are you i'm thirty-two
thirty-two weight by myself thirty-five
thirty-five okay that's close together
do you like older women i mean anytime a
woman looks at you
and she goes
do you like older women and they do a
head tilt
just no she sucks a mean dick there's no
way she does
don't got that god got 2000 you get me
i'll just tell you
she didn't do this so she would like
want to go to church on sunday no no she
went like this and be like let me get
ready so i can start to recall my neck
back to suck some that dick [ __ ] you
like this [ __ ]
i don't i don't think she would be like
i was gonna suck some dick [ __ ] because
she's white white but oh it depends on
what kind of white woman you went
[Laughter]
let me tell you something
you're not going to tell us
do you like older women i mean you're
similar to age yeah i don't really view
it as that
she went do you like older women and
he's like yeah nah
[Music]
i got that gotcha 2 000. well you can
buy by 3 000 [ __ ] good night
do you like older women i mean you're
similar to age yeah i don't really view
it as that
[Music]
he did
i mean you know we're just gonna yeah i
mean yeah i mean
[Music]
what this is what people do in their
head all the time you know when you
match with somebody but you looking
through the pictures you realize they're
ugly you go like yeah what's up or how
you doing and then you stop responding
the other person their head is like i
thought we were having such a good time
what happened
they brought a long ass time ago that's
what happened hi how are you that's dope
hair thank you solid thank you so much i
like it i'm josh thank you nice to meet
you i'm skye nice to meet you you have
hats too i have a few yeah sleeve
absolutely chest piece can we see more
of your tattoos oh sure
they chose violence today they don't
give a [ __ ] can you see your tattoos oh
yeah sure
i'm albin nice to meet you how old are
you i'm 25 how old are you i'm 23. is
that too young for you is that a deal
breaker
um i don't think so okay
[Music]
everybody this episode is getting the
soul crushed
what's your name i'm alvin nice to meet
you nice to meet you i like your tattoos
thank you do you have any tattoos no
these these two there's zero chemistry
here no this is like oil and water and i
don't mean that i just figured it's like
oil and water in two separate jars
no tattoos i want some though what do
you want i don't know that's why i
haven't gotten one yet
oh wow those are the tattoos the
indecisiveness i
want i like somebody who knows what they
want you know tell the priest what does
she want
i know
[Music]
that's not what i was going for
i thought you always say choke me daddy
that's what she looked like she looked
like she won yeah
you know
it goes with it
what do you do what does your life look
like i'm a manager hey it's a boy you
got a whole baby
and right after work i like to
get a run in do some weights this guy
looks like ezra miller if ezra miller
wasn't into kits you know what i'm
saying i don't know who the [ __ ] astro
miller is it's the guy who's playing the
flash but you always get into trouble
yes yes yes yeah yeah yeah you look like
a like a like a lord of the rings
version yeah yeah do you have any other
hobbies
hobbies
i can't really say i'm that anxious
what was up with
[Music]
that yo dead ass this entire video
as like a toothy blow job and she got
braces
yeah the fact that you don't have any
other hobbies i'm a very creative person
i guess my life is never oh my gosh
no it's not cause you're a creative
person you saw your hand going oh yeah
yeah and when you saw it
let's analyze this
you were there girlfriend
you know what i mean you know what i
mean
let's analyze this okay for two seconds
you were there my girl we all saw you
being there
you saw yourself i mean we're watching
the tape of you being there
girl what are you doing is it because
i'm creative no
because i'm a creative person no i just
you're not cute sorry
[Music]
i'm not cute
okay i'm on cute
why did you reject her i don't like uh
colorful hair no that's okay
that's that that scat i want you guys to
appreciate what happened there was what
happened in his head and as patrice
would say then it went into his stomach
you know what i'm saying got edited went
through post-production got rendered
came out what went in his head is like
this colorful ass going out to [ __ ]
punk rock parties getting turned out in
the [ __ ] bathroom and then it went in
here and he came out with
uh i'm not a big fan of rainbows
no
no that's cat you gotta reject and i got
no problem with the lady she could be a
wonderful person i'm just telling you i
could tell the way the wheels turned he
went through that whole like all right
let me pc this [ __ ] up okay uh-huh that
is cat this won't get me canceled last
fantastic
uh
you got too many colors in your hair
that's super yeah
hi
hi
uh what's your name april april if you
don't buzz that because you got colorful
hair uh
cab
cab kevin cap committee cap cap cat uh
what's your name april april austin
austin okay sorry i thought you said
awesome and i was like okay
i like to walk with my dog and not run
with my dog so you're a dogger
do you like dogs
my dog is my child
i am not a dog person it's okay
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's shubert and girl that's you [ __ ]
that's your man but at least i know my
life is ridiculous she's been doing that
[ __ ] like his name's true
like i don't do that in real life you
think i'll just be showing up on days
like you got that goggles
april nice to meet you okay right away
are you attracted to each other do you
find me attractive um i i do not but you
seem funny i appreciate the honesty
though
yes
let's keep watching
danny says he has a good sense of humor
tell her a joke a joke oh you gotta do
me a joke like this no no no no no let
me tell y'all something okay
ain't none worse than feeling like you
got to be somebody's clown so they can
appreciate you if you come up on a girl
she says i don't think you're cute the
last thing you want me to do is like
whoa do you want to see how [ __ ]
funny i am
looking like a goddamn circus clown are
you made out of 11 protons because you
are sodium fine
it's okay come at me i gave my share all
right i know you give her a shirt i
gotta do it too um
[Music]
sorry danny it's nice meeting you too
you know when he leaned back you know
what he's thinking
all the other elves he ever took in his
life i'm gonna haul flashing right
before him
defeat number 932
i'm about to get bust and this one's
going up on youtube so i get to relive
and add to my notches but i already know
how it is and i get to read the comments
and have them all laugh it's fine i
won't read it and then i get to watch
the reaction videos and this them laugh
at me and then i get to have friends and
family send me videos of people reacting
to me getting rejected so hard on
television hey dude hey danny how are
you doing you watching right now god
bless you stay with us get therapy
you'll be okay
godspeed how about your last
relationship
uh my last relationship ended terribly i
was uh out for work i came back home
turns out she cheated on me and also got
pregnant with that guy's child do you
think there's anything that you could
have recognized earlier on definitely i
think it was because i think i noticed
some red flags and stuff like that like
personality just hit a whole 180 but i
think i didn't want to like
like believe it so i was trying to drown
myself in work you know the 2020 was not
my best year
it has nothing to do with any of that
just oh yeah i know it's fine it's
totally fine i appreciate you
this is the only show that could be like
hey yes open up to me
middle of your story don't give up
is that your trauma
there's something so uncomfortable about
it that's great
nah it's okay why did you reject him how
many times did he ask me about myself
she was answering the [ __ ] question
of the button you dumb
let me say the one question that was
asked let me let me say this guys you
guys watching right now okay
this is on i learned
guys okay
you you almost never hear a man say she
didn't ask me enough questions about me
that's something like exclusively women
shouldn't do okay
so this is what i learned about dates
this is gonna work for you twofold
ask them a lot of questions about
themselves they're gonna come out here
and say i don't like it
don't listen to that horseshit okay
those are that [ __ ] horseshit they
love being asked questions about
themselves even when they say they don't
you know you never heard you never heard
a girl say oh he asked me too many
questions about me
nope never happened have you ever heard
that no ever
i've heard the opposite though i've
heard the opposite too many times so if
you're on the date just ask her a bunch
of questions by herself two things are
going to happen not only is she going to
feel like you're interested in her and
her life but you know the second thing
is going to happen she's gonna feel like
she don't know much and then she goes oh
my god he's still mysterious oh my god
he's done this theory
you think do you sit here like talking
about girls being mystery no
hey i could be wrong good point
girl hi
i'm ej april nice to meet you nice to
meet you i really like your hair thank
you thank you thank you so what are you
looking for i'm looking for a
relationship companionship is nice yeah
it is i agree guys that have kids yeah
because i have two kids is it a deal
breaker that he has kids no it's not a
deal breaker
so i'm gonna turn red one more time and
you're gonna personally click it
we'll pay for a second day
it would have been hilarious if you just
hit that button
one time for my [ __ ]
tell me what you're gonna do with that
all
[Laughter]
is
yeah it don't have to make no sense that
[ __ ] was fire it was
ad-libs let's go
they're
the original amigos yes yes but there's
more melodic
[Music]
no
original migos that's
that's
[Applause]
yo that laugh is
that laugh is a lot yo did i ever tell
you i was going on days with this girl
very attractive but she had a bad habit
of snorting
okay bruv
can i tell you something yonda was so
[ __ ] up
i wish
holy [ __ ] i would have preferred
that she didn't look that she would
because
we can manage that
i can't take you anywhere
god bless your soul you know i hope
she's in a good place she did
she's dead to you
i'm glad you caught that i'm glad you
caught that i'm glad you can see that
you
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below